with coronavirus infections now in the
tens of thousands globally and experts
warning of a pandemic people need clear
accurate information
unfortunately on social media that's not
always easy to find what's working in
terms of risk communication what's
scaring people in terms of
misinformation we need a vaccine against
misinformation as well we've all got to
be very responsible and the media has a
very important role in this particularly
the the social media electronic media of
all types so how do you create a vaccine
for misinformation the World Health
Organization's info Demick teams are
asking companies that Facebook and
Google take an active role in filtering
false information search the hashtag
coronavirus on Instagram and if you live
in the UK you'll get a prompt asking you
to visit the NHS website same on
Facebook and Twitter and tik-tok has
partnered with the World Health
Organization to stop misinformation
despite this conspiracy theorists
circumvent detection systems like this
video
speculating that 5g causes coronavirus
it doesn't by the way it uses code words
instead of keywords and as a result this
videos got half a million views on
YouTube when I have to say that word I'm
just gonna say CV the second word this
country that the social media doesn't
like us to talk about too much I'm gonna
say CH the third group that is all over
this thing I'm gonna say the WHO these
are words I'm gonna have to be saying a
lot in this presentation and the more I
say them the more I'm gonna go down in
visibility and I think this is something
that everyone deserves to hear about
posts being shared without fact-checking
has led to very real consequences the
sunday sport tabloid published a story
on two Brits frustration and not being
able to return home featuring a photo of
their face mask tan lines except this
isn't Ted and Marcia it's Harvey and
Shirley Clifford on their holiday 15
years ago Malibu posing for a photo
taken by their son Danny the story
spread rapidly on social media and some
people believed it was real something
Danny says has caused his parents great
distress my mum and dad are nearly 90
they've both got cancer they're
suffering this is stopping them sleeping
at nights now because they think people
really do hate them they haven't got to
grips with the idea that it's a fake and
it's other people that have been
purported to be them other names rather
so this is all very very bad and very
sad that that that innocent people have
been thrown into this it's awful
the WH are created cards debunking
popular myths ranging from how you
cannot contract her own advice off a
package from China how sesame or cannot
be used to protect yourself from the
virus so who is posting this false
information some have tried to use the
confusion surrounding corona virus to
turn a profit
forcing Amazon to remove overpriced
masks and products claiming they cure
the virus and of course anyone with a
big following can get something wrong
ronan keating the nanny tease singer
from the band Boyzone said that ships in
singapore couldn't get him to a port
because of the virus when it turned out
they could he did later remove the post
there are also more malicious types of
misinformation being spread u.s.
officials accused russia of the way she
gives disinformation campaign promoting
the idea that the u.s. is quotes waging
economic war on China by manufacturing
the virus so what's the best way to stay
informed take your advice from the World
Health Organization or if you're in the
UK use the NHS website be skeptical and
double-check information you hear on
social media just because it's from a
friend doesn't mean it's necessarily
true